Matt have you heard about this new
glitch
but
pre-series Dimitri glitches are one of
the most annoying things that can happen
to you in a video game and nothing is
more frustrating than having your
experience ruined by someone who knows
how to weaponize these anomalies against
you not this again with that being said
glitches aren't just problems and over
the years they've provided programmers
with invaluable lessons that have
contributed to the building blocks of
modern competitive games but most
importantly glitches can be goddamn
hilarious
[Applause]
glitches and bugs our programming errors
and oversights that lead to unintended
problems in games bugs tend to be more
serious game breaking mistakes while
glitches are often smaller and less
likely to be a software destructive but
to most people the two words are often
used interchangeably originally however
the term bug was a lot more literal
people had been referring to engineering
malfunctions as bugs for no particular
reason as far back as the 1870s but the
term became common in popular in 1946
when computers were literally the size
of a room the cray-1 is a million times
more powerful than a common home
computer its central processing unit is
made of over 67 miles of interconnecting
wires two operators working on a harvard
mark to log that the computer wasn't
working properly and found the cause to
be a moth that it flown in to one of its
relays they taped them off to their log
and labeled it the first actual case of
a bug being found since then the term
bug has been commonly used to describe
busted programming and every game no
matter how adored has been affected by
them to some extent just look at the
original Super Mario Brothers which had
a bug that could transport players to
the so called - world horrifying mirror
realm where up was down and Mario could
swim in the air or more infamously
pokémon red and blue which had missingno
and a number of more malicious bugs that
were capable of destroying your game if
you caught them oh my god what the [__]
is that bro we seen sir [__] we ain't
never seen before kick that thing look
Jake these days game design is more
complex than it's ever been and with
most titles having hundreds of thousands
if not millions
of interactions it's unrealistic to
expect your code to be prepared for
every possible circumstance while modern
glitches might not be as surreal as
their predecessors they're still very
much ingrained in our gaming experience
league of legends for example is
infamous for its spaghetti code and
while it's functional most of the time
on occasion it can be a real nightmare
[Music]
damage on Timothy shook is in the
millions though the one that's indeed
but League is far from the only MOBA
that's riddled with game janking bugs
and glitches dota 2 has had more than
its fair share too the most absurd and
hilarious of which probably being one
chen players were able to recruit roshan
using holy persuasion bugs aren't just
the affliction of multiplayer games
though and even Bethesda's best titles
are just curated collections of
interactive glitches anyone who's played
skyrim knows exactly what i'm talking
about it's got everything from idiot
shopkeepers maybe you're looking for
something particular to vengeful
chicken-loving townspeople I only killed
a chicken I only kill the chickens [__]
off to whatever the [__] this is
[Music]
but perhaps the most famous bug in
videogame history is World of Warcraft's
corrupted blood plague which also kind
of sounds like a terrible Cradle of
Filth album oh it's just bloody rude
back in 2005 Blizzard added a new raid
to World of Warcraft which featured a
boss that applied the corrupted blood
debuff to players corrupted blood did
constant damage and was even capable of
spreading to nearby uninfected players
in theory that's not a big deal
you lost the debuff after you died or
waited out the duration of its effect
the problem was that Blizzard done
goofed they overlook the fact that
mountain pets were able to carry the
disease with them once you left the raid
all of a sudden everyone was infected
and PCs could contract the disease but
didn't die from it which meant that just
being near one was enough to infect you
people fled to the wilderness for safety
but in the cities the corpses piled up
it took Blizzard almost a month to fix
the bug and it still remains one of the
most incredible programming fuck-ups
of all time oddly enough though
scientists have used the event as a case
study to analyze how people might react
to an actual apocalyptic plague [__]
nerds but not all coding aberrations are
that widespread and devastating some are
just small interactions that slip by
developers and become useful tools in
the hands of competitive players they
evolved from glitches to exploits while
not all exploits are necessarily
glitches most glitches are programming
errors that can absolutely be exploited
and chances are that when you first
experience someone using an exploit
against you you'll swear it's a glitch
all of my stew is still waiting the
patience game coming against pucks I'm
coming out of Street torch while he's
here he sees them now they're straight
they have no idea Smith's looking
confused and dazed one of gaming's most
famous and commonly used exploits is
bunny hopping which emerged with quake
back in 1996 the idea is that certain
games physics systems allow players to
move faster than intended by perfectly
timing their jumps while turning
constantly to maintain forward momentum
and these days although bunny hopping
isn't as prevalent in pro play you'll
still experience it online in csgo
fortnight and apex legends hey want to
play movement exploits like bunny
hopping are littered throughout gaming's
history whether it's skiing in tribes or
case styling in guns the duel what's
more rare however our exploits that stem
from the fundamental design of the game
itself
for example Street Fighter 2 is often
credited with inventing combos the
literal backbone of every modern
fighting game while that's true it
wasn't on purpose
Capcom never intended to let players hit
buttons that quickly one after another
but when fans figured it out the
developers ended up with a hit Erich
Suzuki is a Street Fighter specialist
here at Capcom he's got a special route
combo for us what's it called Eric it's
called Rouge triple hit dragon punch
Danny here cut to a game screen I'll
talk you through it you got it
[Music]
[Applause]
not all exploits get to live long happy
lives though some exist for one brief
beautiful moment before being destroyed
by bound seeking developers the most
infamous example of this in eSports has
to be the fountain hug strategy that
Navi deployed against Hong foo at ti3
the trick involved pairing Chen's test
of faith ability and pudges hook and if
timed correctly the interaction resulted
in Chen teleporting Pudge and his hook
enemy on a one-way trip to the fountain
so has it even been used
the timing on a fountain hook was
crucial and screwing it up would be an
absolute waste of time but in Dendy
skilled hands
it was game-changing if he's gonna try
it again Katie got in that time see you
in the face move
up there we go the Haggadah the fountain
for fountain while fountain hooks can be
traced all the way back to DOTA allstars
most people just viewed it as hard to
execute cheese but seeing it drastically
affect an outcome on eSports biggest
stage valve decided enough was enough
forcing Pudge to hang up his fountain
hook for good with the first blood
update while glitches are a universally
acknowledged problem exploits tend to
split the eSports community into two
groups the first being those that think
they're just a form of cheating and the
second being people who think that
exploits are just creative solutions
that their opponents just don't know
about back with the VXR this is why
Walshy is so dangerous up-close and
personal he will take your face jumps
over B to smack X to cancel right
trigger to shoot you're dead forget
about it but outside of eSports
there's a third class of player those
who strive to break the games they love
just because they can we're coming up
here is actually one of the first
pitches found knowledge
one of the first tricks found in the
game what did you just hold on and it
also creates a floor under you for one
frame and I can use that to avoid hard
falls wait hold on are you saying that
that animation is glitched it's not my
fault he just kind of teleports forward
because he's on a script sort of well
that sounds like a glitch he's
teleporting it's not my fault I go too
fast and try to throw this gun down the
elevator shaft let me save it for oh no
that looks like a glitch the
speedrunning community in particular
celebrates these strange achievements
because they actively seek crazy
glitches that can help them complete
games faster than anyone imagined was
positive
[Music]
so yeah of course glitches can suck when
they hit you out of nowhere no one likes
being on the receiving end of some
game-breaking [__] that developers might
have missed in the last patch but
glitches and bugs are so much more than
annoying programming oversights and they
continue to change the way games are
made and how we play them I personally
love glitches I think it's [__]
hilarious when they mess up character
models what's so funny when I play Red
Dead Redemption I always like roleplay
that I am John Wayne and just play with
my friends like I saddle up pelegrin
we're going let's pick a fight over
there in the game I don't I don't
actually dress up but I put in my
character I become my character most
most nights even when I'm not playing